menschen ziemlich abstoßend ihr wille
bereiten sind freunde wir machen heute
einen fussball challenge lauf das ist
nämlich möglich gemacht worden durch
electronic arts
das weitestgehende handel bugs und jahre
sind ein team und jule und ich sind ein
team allerdings sieht das ganze
zweigeteilt sein challenge und zwar
werden wir erst gegeneinander in teams
fifa 19 gegeneinander spielen und dann
werden wir auf einen fußballplatz gehen
und noch eine outdoor reality hell meter
schießen challenge machen allerdings bin
ich sagen fangen wir erstmal an mit
tiefer also leute ihr seht ihr schon
manchester city gegen paris st
die beiden sind paris die beiden mancity
deshalb jetzt geht's los weil hier
übrigens auch pocher fifa 19 haben dann
ist in der beschreibung unten einen link
da könnt ihr draufklicken da könnte ich
viel von 19 kaufen die leute dafür ging
schon die animation
seid ihr auch bericht hier werden leute
da muss halt wirklich sagen ja und
jünger haben glaube ich vereine noch nie
richtig kiefer gespielt
jetzt 36 ja auch auf andere wäre jede
wir diese spiele gewinnen das team
bekommen übrigens einen punkt und der
fussball challenge ist es dann im fall
ihrer mit frau berichten wie die ganze
zeit dabei als läge bei dieser challenge
bekommt einen punkt und in der anderen
stellen
draußen kann man dann noch mal ein punkt
holen und der der gewinnt das
stadtarchiv machen
das kürzel für den torschuss von jahre
gerade
[Musik]
erhält wir müssen mal vors tor kommen
würde juni zeit
derzeit seien immerhin alter langsam
über den wir alle naturfreunde stoffe
bei denen nicht an sich
[Musik]
und dann veröffentlicht
ich habe einfach gar nicht damit
gerechnet ich hab mir passen gedrückt
jetzt das ist ok und der klima der
offenheit also ganz schön geschockt sind
nicht als die anderen klassen manchmal
sogar juli hatte durchdringen gefühl
nicht wieder
nein ich war ein schöner ich glaube
andere hören
ja
[Musik]
ich möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
jetzt hat sie ihr nicht mehr an
manchester city holt sich also den
siegen dieser partie angekommen auf dem
fußballplatz meine damen und herren es
ist nicht der allerbeste fußballplatz
aber ich meine das reicht für unsere elf
meter trennen auf jeden fall werden wir
dazu machen dass wenn ich aufs tor
schieße steht max im tor versucht den
ball zu halten und halt auch umgekehrt
und venue lauf tor schießt steht ja im
tor jana schießt steht julia im tor
wir sagen ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das elfmeterschießen ist jetzt leider 3
3 unentschieden ausgegangen da max und
jana allerdings bereits die fifa 19
partie mit 3 zu 1 gewonnen haben
die sind juni quasi die verlierer und
ich kriege abschießen
[Musik]
ich habe beide beine kommen wir mit
damit beende ich jetzt auch unser fifa
19 fußball real life challenge pärchen
video wenn es euch gefallen hat das gern
leichter dankeschön an ea dass sie
dieses video hier möglich gemacht haben
und gesponsert haben schon vermuten die
beschreibung findet ihr alle links von
mir und auch die links zu viel von 19
schaut bei max vorbei bei jana bei juli
bei dave danke
[Musik]